Let's talk about the elephant in the room shall
we the hulk my cousin bruce semantics he was of
the hulk wasn't he you know i tried to kill him
Welcome back everyone this will be my full marble
she-hulk episode 2 video there were a whole bunch
of easter eggs and references so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes i will
be doing videos for all the she-hulk episodes and
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post your favorite easter egg from the episode on
the video careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet we'll just start at the beginning
and work our way through shot by shot talking
about wtf moments and easter eggs as we go along
starting with the episode title it was called
superhuman law it was a reference to the superhero
law division of the glk and h law firm that she
is now running as the she-hulk character and her
first case is to win parole for the abomination
and help him get out of prison they made all kinds
of jokes about marvel in general like they made
fun of themselves but also broke the fourth wall
a ton just because that's kind of the tone of the
series making many references to the incredible
hulk movie and making fun of the fact that they
recast the hulk as a completely different person
mark ruffalo becoming the character during
the avengers movie after edward norton in the
incredible hulk that fight was so many years ago
i'm a completely different person now literally
the full name of the law firm is actually a direct
reference to some of the creators of marvel comics
itself it's goodman lieber kurtzman and holloway
but the other names are for martin goodman who
owned the original company that became marvel
comics stanley lieber who was stan lee's
birth name he changed it later in life in jack
kurtzman was jack kirby's original birth name
you also notice when she's walking through the
law firm there are some super meta references
to actual physical comic books so the law firm
itself is right out of the she-hulk comics like
she works there in the comics as well but in
the comics and now on the tv show too they're
doing it because you see it in the background
of their offices the lawyers at the law firm
use in-universe canon comic books to help defend
on the superhero cases i guess that kind of makes
marvel comics canon inside the mcu like there
is a real company called marvel comics creating
comic books based on all these heroes there are
a lot of references to the avengers characters
through the episode like in the world now post
avengers end game they're all celebrities so it
makes sense that there'll be a lot of pop culture
stuff going on around their characters a lot of
people selling merch based on their characters and
in universe comic books being created about them
the actual episode begins with a bunch of news
broadcasts from different stations in los angeles
talking about what happened at her trial at the
end of episode one with things going crazy and her
becoming she-hulk one of the funny things too is
that titania's lawyers are apparently blaming the
incident on her having low blood sugar the actress
who plays titania said that she's not coming back
till episode five so there might be some loose
references to what happened during that episode
but she herself will not be back for several
episodes and it's one of the last broadcasters
here for kzyo who gives her the she-hulk name
from the comics for the first time the person
walking out of the courtroom could be a comic book
creator cameo too there were a couple references
in the episode to comic book creators we find at
the lawyer bard that they all hang out after work
is called legal legalese it's a joke about the
language of lawyers as they speak quote-unquote
legalese she hates the name initially they even
make fun of it like that's a stupid name a super
derivative and it's a bit of a meta joke about
them actually doing that in real life like back in
the 60s it happened all the time like you have a
bunch of derivative names where there'd be female
characters inside popular titles like superman
batman all the avengers comics and to create
female superheroes a lot of them just became
derivative versions of the more popular male
versions of the superheroes one of the exceptions
though is like the wasp so like for instance the
wasp is an original avenger in the comics and
she's not called lady ant-man or like she ant-man
or anything like that she's called wasp she has a
completely different persona she breaks the fourth
wall for the first time in the episode agreeing
to give the people what they want like they're
all cheering for she-hulk she's become this big
celebrity she's like okay fine i'll be she-hulk
one of the other funny meta things now too
is she jokes about having all these student
loans from law school but literally yesterday as
i'm posting this video the us president forgave
a lot of student debt in america they make a
bunch of direct jokes about the avengers saying
that they're mostly billionaires narcissists
adult orphans which is funny because obviously
billionaires mostly an iron man reference but
narcissists and adult orphans could describe
most of the avengers i wouldn't call black widow
and narcissist though but most of them are adult
orphans like most of their parents are dead they
also make a funny call back to that falcon and
winter soldier joke about him not getting paid
like he couldn't get a bank loan because he didn't
have any income to show maternity leave a pension
are they even paid we found that the gamma affects
her a little bit differently from the bruce banner
hulk so when she changes back to shield as she's
getting fired by her district attorney boss we
find out the gamma doesn't metabolize the alcohol
in her system the same way so she gets super drunk
the minute she changes back but if you remember in
episode 1 bruce banner hulk said that the gamma
abilities inside him were healing his arm slowly
that was happening slowly but they were still
healing him while he was still in human form so
the gamma was still active in his body some of you
also predicted that she would get fired because
the jury would be biased against her because
she saved their life and that is the reason in
the episode that they explained she gets fired
and they use that for like a funny montage later
where she tries to get hired by other law firms so
they're like no no you're too much of a liability
here the joke about her being hired by glk and h
for the superhero law division they also pay off
later where he's like yeah i don't care about all
those conflicts i don't care about those people
just tell bob we're moving him to the frozen
north like just to be sadistic just tell him that
it's meant to be a joke about how her boss is
just as bad as a lot of these super villains
even if he doesn't himself have super powers
like a joke about lawyers being really terrible
people they also have a brand new she-hulk theme
song with the she-hulk attorney at law titles and
they even have like a special little joke where
they almost break the fourth wall like it's not
a technical fourth wall break but it's close
to it like it's kind of a meta where the titles
change the text to attorney for hire because she
literally just got fired like referencing what
just happened in the episode the show references
itself several times during the actual episode
like it's just that kind of show it'd be the same
thing if deadpool had his own tv show we get a
couple hulk cameo scenes during the episode from
bruce banner one to just see how she's doing and
then joke about what happens in the episode with
her taking the job with abomination in the history
between them and kind of making fun of marvel in
general in the whole recasting thing with edward
norton being fired and then mark ruffalo being
hired for the avengers movie also revealing that
he is now off planet on that sakar spaceship
going back to sakaar to find out about quote
unquote something like i'll be busy for a while he
doesn't say exactly what it is but they didn't see
that particular scene would tie into future marvel
movies so it is meant to be like a big movie thing
that they'll pay off in the future the only
space-based movies that we know about right now
are guardians of the galaxy 3 the marvel's movie
captain marvel 2 and like maybe avengers 5 in
avengers 6 secret wars and i don't think that he's
going to be in the marvels movie and i don't think
that he's going to be in guardians of the galaxy
3. so there's going to be like an avengers 5 kang
dynasty reference or it'll be something that they
reference at the end of the episode and it'll tie
back in with what's happening in captain america
4 new world order or the thunderbolts movie
i talked about how this could have something to
do with the planet whole storyline they could be
circling back around and doing some scar son of
hulk storyline when it could lead that to a world
war hulk storyline eventually but you can let me
know in the comments like why do you think that
he is going back to zakar now and what is this
going to tie in with in the movies then on the
internet page that she's staring at there are a
ton of easter eggs all over the place so there's a
wolverine easter egg that was actually really cool
right underneath the iron man reference man fights
with metal claws in bar brawl that is literally
the scene from the first x-men movie in the bar
if you're not a big comic book reader wolverine
is a character also debuted in the comics for
the first time during incredible hulk number
181 so it would be really cool if they debuted
a new mcu version of the wolverine inside a hulk
project really want to see that wolverine versus
hulk in the mcu at some point whichever version
of wolverine they want to use whether or not
hugh jackman wants to come back for that there's
also finally finally a reference to that giant
stone celestial tiamet in the indian ocean first
reference in a new marvel project movie or tv show
since the eternals movie came out like that's how
long it's been everybody's been joking about this
forever like when are they finally gonna reference
that in a new marvel project well they just did
there's references to ant-man thor the avengers
like find ant-man i think this is meant to be a
game like where's waldo finding ant-man in
large crowd shots because he's super tiny
norse mythology for thor new asgard there's also
a dedicated tab just for news about the avengers
there's also a new qr code here that points you
to the she-hulk landing page on marvel.com and
gives you a free copy of she-hulk number one in
2004. they actually did the same thing in episode
one giving you a free copy of the original
first shield appearance in savage she-hulk
so i'm expecting them to do this in every single
episode where you get like a qr code with a free
new comic book in every episode because they did
the same thing in the moonlight episodes they'll
probably do this in a lot of the future marvel
disney plus series too with qr codes in the
background the whole thing with the swiss village
might be a reference to arnhem zola because he was
swiss it's not a lot very or doctor doom reference
because that's in eastern europe and when her mom
texts her about their family dinner zoom in
enhance you notice her lock screen on her
phone is literally captain america's ass that is
america's ass when she goes to her parents house
the number on the house 663 might be a reference
to amazing spider-man 663 which featured she-hulk
it also featured the avengers in the fantastic
four fantastic four debuting at the beginning
of marvel phase six pretty soon if her father
looks familiar that's because he's being played
by mark lynn baker from perfect strangers during
the dinner they also joke about being strangers
we finally find out what's going on with the ched
character who they mentioned in episode one he's
her cousin and they made it seem during episode
one like he was also a genius in the family but
they could have just been joking about it because
it seems kind of like a dumb ass during the
episode like they make a big deal about how he's
a manager at best buy and he's a really big deal
because of that when the mother mentions the use
of person at their local coffee shop who wants
to be a superhero that's not the same person
as kamala khan's father his name is also yusuf
but they live in jersey city on the other side of
the country so this is like a completely different
person her father makes a whole bunch of hawkeye
jokes asking what he does with all of his arrows
obviously she doesn't know but we literally just
saw that during the hawkeye series they answered
that question because kate bishop also asked
the question turns out he in fact does go back
and pick up the trick arrows just like her father
guessed like does he go back and pick him up seems
kind of dangerous to leave those lying around
ched makes a reference to avengers end game in
the hulk's infinity gauntlet snap when saying that
he saved billions of people with the snap of his
fingers she references eternity when talking
to her father about becoming she-hulk which we
literally just saw the cosmic concept in thor love
and thunder eternity is one of the most powerful
cosmic concepts it's literally the embodiment
of the entire mcu universe that's why it's body
looks like it's made up of all the stars because
it literally encompasses the entire universe it
just anthropomorphized in this human looking
shape her father makes more jokes about the
events of the incredible hulk movie saying that
she's not the first hulk in the family and she
did not destroy a city there's several references
to incredible hulk during the episode which they
also referenced later during the abomination scene
about destroying most of harlem when she says she
feels like a weight has been lifted metaphorically
she's making more of an existential reference
about how this weight has been lifted off of her
shoulder she feels much better with her powers but
also it's meant to be set up for the post credit
scene with her actually helping her father do all
the household chores which he claimed he needed
her help with like she's literally lifting a bunch
of heavy stuff around for him and also a bit of a
reference to the end credits easter egg here where
they have a tribute to the muscle beach she-hulk
comic book art with her literally lifting weights
she gets hired by holloway to the law firm for the
superhero division they explain what's going on
with their new job representing all the super
villains the superheroes they make a bunch of
jokes about everybody else just flipping out at
the sight of her i already explained the easter
egg with all the comic books on the spinner
racks in their offices like how they actually
use those to help win their cases she breaks the
fourth wall again to complain about only being
hired because she looks the way that she does ann
breaks the fourth wall again to make another joke
about a random answer to a question she didn't
hear what was going on there when she said that
she's agnostic was him just asking her about what
she thought of the new superhuman law division
that they just started in what she thought about
actually becoming she-hulk in general one of the
terms of her accepting the job was nikki being her
paralegal she's like her best friend she follows
her around to all of her different jobs you might
recognize josh jagara as he pokes his head in here
as prometheus from arrow he's playing pug on the
show he's a real character from the comics called
augustus who's just a lawyer who falls in love
with her and works at the same law firm he also
debuted in she-hulk number one he's mostly a good
character in the comics so i don't know if there's
anything weird that they have going on with the
character during the series or if he's just going
to be a character who tries to help her and has
like a huge crush on her he also has a weird poop
thing going on too like please poop over in here
this is the good bathroom the evil of the jokes
about him giving her the abomination case she
makes all the references to incredible hulk like
oh he tried to kill my cousin bruce banner the
prison that he's at is the same one the damage
control operates that we saw during the miss
marvel series that the people have been sent to
the reason why abomination probably requested
her specifically is because he felt like it would
help his case like obviously there's this long con
that it seems like he's playing during the episode
and part of it is making everyone believe that
he's reformed like the hulk literally says that
abomination sent him a really nice card in one
of those funny haikus that he's been creating and
they basically buried the hatchet so like there's
no bad blood between the two of them but really i
think we all believe that there's something really
tricky going on with the character like he's just
pretending to peddle all this new age bullcrap
to get out of prison and he probably requested
jennifer walters because he felt like it would
help that case the car number here 1202 might be
a reference to the wolverine hulk team-up comic
book in 2002 the cell that he's in a113 i think
is also meant to be a reference to avengers 113
which was a scarlet witch and vision story mostly
and i think the idea with these security lasers
are that they're built only to stop people with
superpowers so they don't affect her while she's
in human form doesn't totally make sense i think
they're really just there to stop people like the
abomination from getting through the c31 right
next to his cell might be another thunderbolts
thunderbolt ross red hulk comic book easter egg
to hulk 31 it could also be a reference to the
immortal hulk number 31 as well too she makes a
silence of the lamb joke quoting the movie serve
me up with some fava beans and then a nice chiaty
i also think that's meant to foreshadow him trying
to play her because during the actual silence of
the lamb's movie hannibal lecter tries to escape
from prison and get free so he can go on a killing
spree again an abomination is really just trying
to do whatever he has to to get out of prison
we learn he's been in prison this whole time since
the events of incredible hook and in that time
he's learned how to change back to human form and
it's meant to be this dark parallel for him saying
that he got super zen with like hulk getting super
zen and forming the professor banner version of
hulk the difference with abomination though i
think is that he's just pretending to be good
he basically quotes his entire comic book
backstory about how he's russian raised in
the uk and then on loan to the us military and
when he mentions the mystery seven prison pals
that he made the past several years that could be
a reference to the thunderbolts characters like
he could be writing to people like val baron zemo
us agent the other thunderbolts related characters
but he also says that those mystery people bought
him a piece of land and i think that's going to be
paid off in future episodes like where you see
him holding this support group here so some of
those mystery people could just be part of like
this new age stuff that he's peddling and using
that to bilk people of their money and use it to
get out of prison but i think we all believe that
he's going to join a future thunderbolts team like
he's going to be their version of a hulk character
on the team he makes a bunch of references about
trying to kill the hulk in the incredible hulk
movie like let's address the elephant in the room
the way he plays it though he says he only went
crazy because of the super soldier serum like he
blames the serum itself for causing him to do all
these things which we know is a lie because the
serum just amplifies what you already are like it
doesn't change your personality so i think that's
also meant to be a big clue that he's lying about
all this they even kind of play it up as a joke
too like he gets way too teary-eyed and she's
like no no you don't need to do that you just need
to be authentic when you're talking to the jury
then like i said they have that big scene where
the hulk makes all the jokes about being recast
as mark ruffalo later and bearing the hatchet with
the abomination like oh that movie was so long ago
i am completely different person literally and
like i said you could post all your theories in
the comments why you think that he's going back
to sakaar hulk also literally references the
name of the show itself out loud saying she-hulk
attorney at law that's the name of the actual show
then they show the footage of abomination in
the shangshi movie in that underground fight
ring with wong in macau playing it like it was
a prison break and it just happened recently
and now because she's his attorney she has to deal
with it breaking the fourth wall to complain to us
the audience about it so just to chart the
timeline this basically lets you know that
the events of the she-hulk series take place
like right after the shangshi movie basically
so it's not that long after the events of avengers
end game and i think this is part of the reason
why wong shows up initially like he will help out
with the abomination case because he was spending
so much time with him in that underground fight
ring the only extra scenes that they have in the
in credits animation from episode one are more
scenes of her actually joining the glk and h
law firm her parents house in she-hulk form
all these scenes are meant to be taken from
the events of the post-credits scene where like
she's in she-hulk form helping her parents do
household chores and then they have the actual
post credit scene where they pay off the joke
from earlier where her father's like oh yeah
i have some stuff i need you to help me with
where she literally just walks around doing
household chores like everybody has to do
when they visit their parents like they
always have to do common household chores
i'm not sure how many episodes this abomination
case is going to take up because it does seem like
it's going a little bit of a slower burn it might
just be next week's episode the episode after that
and then if abomination comes back it might be
later in the series because it does sound like
she's going to be working on a bunch of different
cases through the episodes so like when daredevil
shows up the case that he's working on might be
a little bit different because in the incredible
hulk movie they tore up most of new york city
daredevil is from new york city it could have
something to do with that but it could just be a
completely different case if you spotted any other
big easter eggs or references in the episode that
i didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments my full she-hulk episode 3
video will post next week as soon as they release
it i'll do a new she-hulk episode 3 trailer video
tomorrow too and also because house of the dragon
is back my full house of the dragon episode 2
video will post on sunday after that's released
a lot of really cool tv coming from a bunch of
different sources really soon everyone click
here for my house of the dragon episode 2 trailer
video and click here for all my she-hulk episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!